the natasha that we saw in uh infinity
ward end game
is actually jelena and moving forward
elena will be this expert
skrull hunter she'll get resurrected
after end game they'll give her the
super
soldier serum i'm friends with the
avengers i'm friends with captain
america
i'm friends with iron man rest in peace
i'm friends with
scarlett johansson
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars black
widow is confirmed to
pass the baton to florence pew a baton
she never got from her older sis joe and
little women
and now she's getting in the mcu yes
guys i do sometimes watch other movies
and little women reminded me of my
sisters and of my neighbor who looked a
lot like timothy shalom hay
it charmed me in all kinds of places hey
this is
rogue theory i'm eric voss reclaiming my
time in the hosting chair from our man
our bottom line
tommy back to old great to be back in
the
uh panelist seat uh much more relaxing i
was so excited that i shaved for today's
show
uh and uh i wish you all the best of
luck today uh hopefully used one of our
eight different grooming sponsors on
this channel to do it
uh but none of them are sponsoring this
episode so we won't mention them until
they pay us
i i actually used expressvpn to shave my
face
somehow it works get a real close shave
there um also return to the show is
comedian
and one time nick fury cosplayer in a
live scroll search bit of my
self-canceled variety show
erica wusu welcome back buddy
hey everybody i actually i trimmed my
beard today with bang energy
big bang somehow somehow these things
work in all kinds of ways
and of course our friend and toby
maguire stan angelica trey
hi i too was so excited that i shaved
today
black widow director kate shortland
revealed in an interview that black
widow won't merely reunite scarlett
johansson natasha romanov with an old
frenemy florence puja elena belova but
confirmed that the baton will be passed
to florence pugh
and propel her on her own storyline in
the mcu's future this is a huge deal
because we knew natasha died in an end
game but there have been you know all
kinds of theories that
black widow could somehow resurrect
scarlett johansson some crazy multiverse
related away some bonkers
explanation that i probably made a dozen
videos about but now
it is pretty clear that florence pugh is
going to be taking the reigns
she's landing the bird it's exciting
times so i want you three
to pitch me on how exactly this movie
black widow is going to pass the torch
the baton to set up lawrence pew to take
over the mantle
in the future of the marvel cinematic
universe all right tommy what's what's
your theory my man
my theory uh we all know in the movie
black widow uh we're looking to see
in the beginning at least natasha and
elena are going to face off but i
believe by the end of the movie they
will literally have a face-off
in that their faces will change they
will saw
each other's faces off and trade them
like they're derek jeter baseball cards
and the year is 1998. so here's what i
think
they're gonna they're gonna swap faces
uh the natasha that we saw
in uh infinity ward end game is actually
jelena uh and this so this would explain
why
uh nat's vested infinity war is the same
vest florence pugh is wearing
in the black widow trailer also it
explains the blonde hair switch i know
stay with me guys
okay i know this is out there you've got
some interesting evidence i want to see
you're already typing a comment i ask
you to pause for a moment okay
all right so the black widow we all know
and love uh basically uh
is is is the same person until civil war
after which point uh that black widow
now lives in florence pugh's body and
what an experience that we would all
like
to spend a day or a few years in
florence pugh's body right
so the red skull let's see on voramir
makes the line
he says this is natasha son or
sorry son this is that's a whole other
face-off this is natasha
daughter of ivan and natasha doesn't
really
uh understand that she doesn't recognize
that name
i know what you're gonna say eric i can
see you ramping up you're gonna say that
the sacrifice doesn't mean
as much if it's jelena actually
sacrificing herself and not that to
which i say
that's right maybe not maybe not okay
because we will learn in black widow i
think
that clint and elena also had a
friendship which would explain why
natasha uh in the infinity war and game
movies
remembers budapest differently because
it's not actually nat
it's jelena her experience in budapest
with uh with hawkeye
uh is very different that's why she
remembers it differently but they're
still good friends
her sacrifice clint losing her still
means something to him okay they have a
separate friendship
men can be friends with multiple women
okay i know a lot of
girls that i've dated haven't understood
that but sometimes the free bird's gotta
fly
okay you gotta have a flock all right so
let me explain all this underscores all
right the reason they would switch
okay is this underscores how the red
room really stripped away
the souls of these people and their
identities and turned them into these
killing machines
and now both natasha and elena will do
anything
anything to remove the red uh morality
sins
in their ledger and move towards
redemption so eulena
taking the place of nat is is in a way a
redemption for her
and and then you know the soul and
spirit of natasha
as i said up until the civil war movies
will live on in florence pews yolina
what a delightful solution for one actor
looking to exit a franchise and another
actor looking to expand in a franchise i
yield the remainder of my time
to buffalo bill's highlights yeah tommy
you have
explained and illustrated this whole
idea of the face swap
concept in a much more thorough way
because you know
i brought this up in a couple videos
before but i kind of just like
softball lobbed it like i don't really
know how this would work in the future
of the mcu but like the stuff you
pointed out about in-game
does make total sense right the
sacrifice while when you first bring up
this idea that
the natasha that we saw in those two
movies is actually you know the identity
of florence pugh's character
it doesn't cheapen it as long as they do
what they need to do in this movie
and reframe that with like a quick
simple montage
just because we haven't seen it on on
film yet doesn't mean that elena
belova's character hasn't had this long
history
with clint barton that could reframe
those moments on vormir
as even more emotional like there's been
five years through the blip in which who
knows what their relationship could have
been
uh a decade before that in which she
could have had a
some other kind of friendship with her
and like the black widow
as a title could apply to several
different characters
uh he could have like a sister ship bond
with both natasha
and elena and that could be something
that this movie reveals
and reframes the moments moment you know
in that moment of in-game is something
even more impactful and meaningful
the fact that one person would be able
to like give up their own life
just because it isn't natasha rumanov it
doesn't mean it's
not a beautiful sacrifice that breaks
your heart
uh and that might explain why we didn't
see her funeral in endgame
and all these other kind of questions we
have about her uh and
yeah this could be something that's
really cool and it is something that
happens in the comics this idea of the
face off even though
it seems ridiculous when you mention it
all right for your point rewards
um i have to come up with some new way
to do it i wanted to do shots
of vodka as they do in the trailer but
we're out of vodka all we have is
jin uh and jin is a you know it's a
london beverage
i think they'd be very insulting to our
russian watchers um so instead i'm going
to do something that's even more painful
to do shots of
of uh energy who did not sponsor this
episode
but um their star blast flavor not my
favorite flavor so
um in order to not get also too hammered
for all the work
i do after we tape this and i've uh
gushed about your theory way too much
but i'm gonna
gush this bang in my mouth
two shots gush
oh and you know i made the mistake these
are
this is a big shot glass this is a
miniature guinness pint glass and i've
been doing full ones of it so you guys
all have double bones
oh god yeah you're also not sleeping
tonight boss so yeah
with that or i'll be sleeping forever
okay hear me out so i think that
just based off of the trailer elena is
somehow she's probably going to die at
some point and
maybe she'll get resurrected after end
game like i don't know maybe they'll
give her the super
soldier serum or something like that and
then yeah and then she'll come back
and sort of resume the
the black widow legacy you know i think
that she's going to end up doing
some sort of martyr situation with
taskmaster
between you know the current you know
natasha ramanov
and she's going to sacrifice herself
and it's going to be really heartfelt
and really sad and uh we're gonna think
that's
the end of her and then we're gonna
we're gonna see her again and i'm pretty
excited to see more
more black widows so yes yeah and i love
that uh the idea of using
the super soldier serum to do this i
mean we do have the shots in the trailer
of someone you know doing the thing
where they they flick the syringe
because you always got to flick it just
to make sure
the flows the flow's nice you know gotta
flick a purse
um uh and uh thunderbolt ross is tying
into this
and we know from the first hulk movie
that that or you know the second hulk
move the first mcu hulk movie that that
guy's been like tinkering with super
soldier serum
from the beginning so that'd be like an
interesting uh deeper layer to his
history that maybe he's involved with
like the super soldier serum
uh now i have to i have to ask hey trey
where do you think uh what do you think
is next
what's this new storyline she's being
propelled on in the mcu is just going to
be like
more more spy [ __ ] i definitely think
it's going to be
more spy stuff i think it's a lot of
it's going to be reestablishing
black widow now with this new identity
you know everyone talking about
natasha and things like that and her
just sort of establishing herself maybe
everyone dealing with the grief of it
and it's going to be a little clunky it
might be a little awkward but
yeah i think it's just going to be a lot
more spy stuff maybe
training and her trying to prove herself
so i will give you one bang shot
angelica for your theory
yeah knock it back
[Music]
that's it's a is it cold
is it lukewarm it's lukewarm because i
took it out this morning and i meant to
do that thing where you wrap a wet paper
towel on it and kind of freeze nuke it
in the
freezer for like you know 15 minutes and
forgot to do that
so it's uh all right it's gonna be it's
gonna
it's gonna hurt it's gonna hurt at the
end
um all right who is uh who's next all
right
so natasha is gonna pass off the mantle
to elena
of the leader of the red room she's just
gonna shed that entirely because in the
comics
natasha is famous for being the best
assassin to come out of the red room
training facility in russia or wherever
the hell they had that
be filmed where it was cheap for
production and
elena in the comics is an expert at
getting information from people
so she's good at seeing if people are
double crossing or if they're double
agents
what have you what have you uh she's
like the best friend
of a person who's dating somebody that
might be shady and you can find out
everything she needs to know through her
instagram
so uh elena i think
will have a battle with the taskmaster
uh because the taskmaster what i think
his real agenda is is unveiling the
secret invasion
that's coming with the scroll i think
he's on to what nick fury has going on
with the scroll in some way shape or
form
and his big thing is he wants to use all
this avengers uh
fighting moves and technology to kind of
pull back the curtain on what's going on
with the skrull and nick fury uh so
elena will be tasked with trying to
break him down for information
and moving forward elena will be this
expert scroll hunter
whose only mission in life is to find
out who
skrull really are and to uncover and
stop this invasion of alien green people
i love that uh i'm sorry i for everyone
who didn't know uh
erica woodson i used to we had a sketch
team and we all had these dumb pet names
for each other and
owusu was woo-woo um so i might
accidentally call him sometimes
uh but here's why i love it because one
thing that i'm
you know a little concerned about going
into what we'll probably see a secret
invasion storyline in mcu's future is
like natasha romanov was such a big part
of that like she was the one who's like
you know what if you want to figure out
who's this girl just shoot them shoot
them through the leg you know if they
bleed green
they're a squirrel shoot first ask
questions later with natasha presumably
dead in the mcu
i would love if elena bulova can play
that part like she's the instrumental
badass
and a secret invasion storyline where
people are like well
we got we know this one person is going
to lead this the
anti-squirrel campaign because like the
way the scroll are set up in mcu right
it's like they're friendly
so you can imagine there'd be kind of
like another sort of civil war
over whether the squirrels are good guys
or bad guys and she can be on the side
of like
look i've been trained my entire life to
determine if someone's like
lying to you if they're a double agent
they're deceitful trust me i'll take
care of it people rally to that side
yeah florence pugh i think would have a
ton of fun
with that role um so do you think uh
taskmaster um is trying to
expose it is he like a conspiracy
theorist who like has watched every bit
of media of every avengers level event
and he's like wait there's a little
green guy like joaquin phoenix and signs
like there's a green dude in the
background
like whoa whoa i gotta they're covering
it up i'm gonna bring down
every you know spy agency who's been
hiding this from humanity i'm gonna blow
it open
like is that the kind of guy we're
talking about here he could be you know
because
social media and youtube type things
exist
in this mcu world so he could have just
watched a bunch of footage
and seen some scroll in the background
kind of morphing and changing into other
people
uh but what i think is something a
little deeper so
the actor playing uh the character rick
mason in the movie
black widow is supposed to be this actor
named ot
fogbenel i think is his name fans don't
come after me don't dox me
so ot fong plays his character rick
mason so who he might be taskmaster but
he also
might be nick fury's son
so as a you know uh
cast aside son who's angry at his pops
for always being a double agent
always absentee always lined everybody
that could be his big mission in this
movie
is to take down his father's uh
cooperative mission with the scroll
and stop the secret invasion that is
awesome
because you got to imagine like uh
there's so much about nick fury's light
that we don't know and we saw at the end
of captain marvel he's just like
eating dinner with with some scrolls
like it's established that has
in the mid-90s he just had this
relationship with them and then far from
home
like all the way to like 2023 he's been
working with them behind the scenes i'm
going to give you
which i'm regretting doing this but uh
three
three shots a bag three shots
you're poor pancreas i mean you're lucky
pancreas ah
one
oh i actually wish it was vodka
all right well these are some great
theories uh we're going to move on with
some people who helped us make this
episode uh thanks to today's sponsor
adamandeve.com
so adam and eve says the best part of
staying at home
is playing at home all of this down time
gives us some time
to get down have any of you tried adam
and eve before this place this is a
pretty
a classy service to help you feel a
little less classy once you get in those
sheets
or the couch or the couch or the kitchen
table
uh on the counter yeah
ooh hammock in the corner in the shower
wherever shaggy
did it oh yeah adam and eve's there
i was thinking cartoon shaggy and that
was a different image
the mystery machine wherever you want to
do it yeah oh scoobs
boss
well you can take advantage of this
downtime and choose almost any item from
adamandeve.com at 50
off when you do you'll also get 10 free
boredom busting gifts
including six spicy movies a three-piece
bonus kit
and best of all free shipping delivered
discreetly to your front door because
this is something that might get left on
your front door and you don't want your
weird neighbor
knowing what you're getting delivered
it's not like every other amazon package
just one special
and uh more essential than you know the
jumbo size
bag of starbursts that you ordered um
this one will uh
give you all kinds of new type of
sweetness
sweet adam and eve oh they'll be bursts
sarah they just won't be scared you'll
remember forever
also starbursts are essential i'll have
you know true
sure all right all right first sir i
agreed uh all
shopping at home is more convenient
right now and shopping for adult stuff
is
much more convenient you don't want
things to get too awkward with the fedex
guy you've recently become best friends
with
just remember to use offer code theory
that's t-h-e-o-r-y
at check checkout adam and eve has
thousands of products to make you
glad you're staying at home go to
adamandeve.com and use that offer code
theory spicy read yeah
also we want to thank our friends at
expressvpn
see sometimes our online research for
new rockstars videos takes us into some
questionable directions uh and
questionable erections as a result
we've done entire videos on the sexual
history of hulk and emperor palpatine
felt things i didn't want to feel well
it's times like those when it doesn't
matter what mode you use or how many
times you clear your browsing history
your internet service provider
can still see every disgusting site that
you've visited
and that is why whether you're at home
or you're at work we use expressvpn
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers
so that your isp can't see the sites you
visit expressvpn keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available expressvpn runs
seamlessly in the background you just
tap one button and you are protected
and it's available on all your devices
phones computers smart tvs
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by cnet and
wired
visit my exclusive link expressvpn.com
rogue
and you can get an extra three months
free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn dot com slash
rogue expressway and dot com slash rogue
learn more
thanks expressvpn now my secrets stay
with me
and me alone and they die with me after
the end of this episode
probably all right uh moving on every
week we play a game of rogue theory with
our patrons on the new rockstars discord
server this week we had some patrons
pitch
theories about how an existing mcu
villain could return
jay stender and dr zoidberg had some
really really great theories but it was
our buddy
that mcu guy who was the winner they
wondering why i'm wearing this shirt
he gave me this shirt he designed this
last time i trust someone
lost a nice shirt he's uh he's a great
guy uh big supporter of ours for a while
now
and he pitched a really fun theory that
iron man 2 villain
justin hammer is uh behind the scenes
collaborator of taskmaster
andreykov and black widow they also
found a way
to tie in the elements from luke cage
and he's just a shield
since i think he was you know at the
same prison he was at seagate right like
so he's at
you know he's he's there i just love
this idea of getting sam rockwell
back in the mcu and find another way to
get that guy dancing on screen because
we saw him in fosse verdin
the guy loves to cut the rug he can move
and uh yeah get justin hammer back in
there he's been around why hasn't he
been back
it's time it's time hammer camera time
as some might say it was right there it
was right there how did i miss it
that's right well all of you watching
can play as well have your theory read
on episode rogue theory by becoming a
patron
at patreon.com new rockstars all right
uh moving on we
just learned that marvel studios is
sadly sitting out of the comic con
at home online event meaning that kevin
feige
is planning on announcing things like
black widow falcon winner soldier on
disney plus maybe even a fantastic four
reboot movie separately doing his own
thing and unfortunately couldn't
announce this before
we uploaded a video predicting marvel's
comic con
panel details confirmed dirt but
assuming that feige will now make these
big future announcements his own way
because the future's coming one way or
another i want you guys to pitch me
the wildest dream announcement for the
mcu
that you would lose your [ __ ] over if
feige were to drop it in his own
non-comic-con online panel uh i have
been thinking
about the disney's acquisition of fox
and how that opened up all of these uh
these new uh uh avenues for them to
explore the marvel universe
and uh the biggest thing to me has been
the x-men like how were they gonna do
the x-men there was just
an x-man movie a year ago
dark phoenix so to me i think the big
announcement is going to be
a tv show an x-men disney plus tv series
i think they're going to do
kind of almost uh where the cartoon in
the 90s took off they're going to kind
of recreate that vibe a very fun
very light-hearted but still
action-packed
disney plus multi you know obviously
millions of million dollar budget same
with mandalore in the way they did
mandalorian
tv show that they can then they take the
pressure away of recasting
they could they're talk we assumed
they'd recast the tv show version of
this
and then if those characters work well
they can integrate them into the mcu
immediately
there doesn't have to be an x-men reboot
four years down the line
we can have an x-men tv show next year
that brings those characters into the
mcu
immediately so my uh the thing that
would make me
happiest aside from howard the duck and
and spider-ham teaming up would be
um would be an x-men tv show
and hell make it a sitcom like saved by
the bell and have it be a school themed
x-men tv show
that would be that's my theory just
quicksilver going timeout
and just runs right now quicksilver is
very very problematic very
very mean revealed to be a real scumbag
i would love to see that because
honestly
i mean i was a i think i was a teenager
like pre-teen
when the first x-men movie came out and
i remember wanting to go to xavier
institute i was like i want to be here
i want to have mutant powers and i would
daydream about talking to like iceman or
something so yeah that sounds awesome
yeah a lot of us said daydreams about
iceman
shawn ashborn animorphs that guy he can
do anything
at all but hey you know it always comes
back to animorphs with you
i find a way to get it back home by the
way i always i lay in this bird
tobias are still on record you [ __ ] up
son you shouldn't have become an eagle
you shouldn't or falcon or whatever
red-tailed hawk red-tailed
all right let's get back to this kevin
feige possible announcement uh who wants
to go next
so i've been noticing lately villains
are getting pretty popular and the
relatable villain
is getting very very popular and we're
starting to see
a lot of media uh you know centralized
around these
villain characters i was thinking what
if we got like a killmonger movie or
show yeah yeah everyone loves killmonger
and so we could potentially have it
where we thought he died
but he's actually he's actually alive
and similar to tommy we could wrap
in or tie in all of the like the x-men
you know universe into it because in
x-men forever
uh killmonger actually teams up with an
evil storm
and so yeah how much would you want to
see that so like a killmonger show or
movie
and then you could tie an evil storm and
have that sort of plot going in and you
tie in the x-men that way
i would love to see that i think
everyone would be open to it
and we love the relatable villain
villains are so hot right now
yeah and uh and so is michael b jordan i
mean that
could that like you could do something
like he gets resurrected you know they
they had him buried in the ocean and
maybe the atlanteans resurrect him or
you can do a prequel of how he got the
name killmonger
and like what this guy was doing before
the events of black panther because you
know
he's been on a ton of missions he he has
all these scars for each of his
kills or might get that wrong or they do
that yeah like he's great he's a cool
guy
yeah and i could just imagine kevin
feige like in this live stream
being like oh well you thought you were
done with michael
oh
oh here we go the moon it's it's got
kill longer on that's where he's dead
all right alusu what do you got i have
got
uh definitely accolades for uh
jungkook's pitch that's awesome i would
love to see killmonger in another
movie yeah but for me what i think kevin
feige is going to bless us with
um is a character movie that we've been
waiting for we've been itching for
fans of the civil war comics have wanted
forever
they teed this character up super
mysterious at the end of guardians vol
2.
we are getting an adam warlock movie
it's happening that's what kevin flagy's
gonna announce
he's gonna come out of that gold
sarcophagus thing
[ __ ] up in the mcu and
and he's going to have some conflict
with the scroll i'm all about the scroll
today
they are my public enemy number one so
adam warlock's gonna go to war with a
sprawl
and it's gonna be some uh uh cartoon
infinity saga
stuff or comic book infinity swagger
stuff mixed in with secret evasion stuff
on our tv screens and hopefully one day
movie theater screens
and ultra 4k imacs it's gonna be
fantastic and here's my wild pitch
adam warlock is gonna be played by none
other
than a marvel trained beefed up timothy
chalamet bringing it full circle
adam we're like they gotta give him
blonde locks whoa fantastic
okay oh little little boy
adam warlock oh man 24 right now so by
the time they do it
he's like an adult-ish he's forever 15.
yes
he does an age he's one of the vampires
who is cursed as a child and just stays
a child forever
there's old civil war photos of uh of
timothy
right now yeah yeah right next to robert
pattinson from like 1863.
yeah yeah they're all children uh i do
love that um
uh let's see i will award one of you
um uh tommy i think i have to ward you
because i do want to see a live action
x-men
so you will get the uh the bang shot
which feels like it's shut yeah real
shock
all right okay all right oh yeah you're
right i'm never going to sleep and my
heart is now beating three times as fast
i'm like what would happen if the
grinch's heart really did grow that big
it would burst out of his chest and he'd
cough up blood
oh no no all right okay yeah don't do
that yeah
yeah but all can change as we move on to
real questions are you seeing blood
vessels burst in my eye
we're worried about you dude i could i
could breathe i could breathe i could do
this
i'm gonna land this bird i'm gonna land
this bird all right
all right uh road question number one
there's a new virtual escape room themed
off of the 90s pop song
mambo number five by lou vega where they
make the lyrics scary by making all of
the names
he lists his victims oh my god
i'm really just reading this for the
first time now what other hit pop song
could be easily made scary i've got one
um does everyone know alicia keys girl
on fire
yes yeah yeah oh no
no no this not what you think not what
you think okay um
so what if she was like a pyromaniac
this girl is on fire and she's just like
setting everything on fire and like yeah
yeah definitely not about
a witch being burned at the stake that's
what she's saying since she screams
as soon as you said that i realized that
and i was like here let's just take that
imagery out of your mind
she's an arsonist way lighter yes
nice yeah my mind definitely went to
another place i thought it was a
adam and eve product gone wrong and the
girl was on fire
we don't keep shame here no no not at
all
that's right if you like that hot wax
power to you just
do it safely have a safe word that's
your thing you know
safety first i've i i've always been
attracted to fires
uh you know eric i was going to
um i was going to say um
uh rock your body by the backstreet boys
but you inspired me eric
earlier when you brought up the seminal
shaggy
hit it wasn't me and i thought what if
there was an escape room
where you play a private investigator
trying to
uh solve a meritable pro marital
marital problem by investigating where
an affair took place
so oh did they have the affair on the
counter
no did they have it on camera no
do they have it in the shower i don't
know uh
picture this they were both buck naked
banging on the bathroom floor
uh that could be the answer so you go
through what i consider a sensible
two-bedroom condo uh and looking for
clues of where the sexual tryst occurred
it's all sponsored by adam and eve so
there's a tie-in here and
uh at the end of the day you're treated
to um
a socially distanced concert by shaggy
and other
great artists of the 90s including uh
darius rucker
and jamiroquai jamiroquai will be there
as well
and at the end sean i love that this is
it's topped
off by atlantis morissette uh
singing all of the songs from jagged
little pill and in the end
the whole experience the experience
costs forty thousand dollars
and it
and then dave and then dave coulier
comes up and then cuts
it out it being your spleen and then he
just holds it and that's what makes it
scary
oh does it have to be scary i thought it
just had to be an escape room i'm sorry
well this is supposed to be scary but i
do love the idea that
uh nothing's scarier tommy than
infidelity that's right what afraid
monogamy to me is the safest place
all right what do you got so
i think a virtual escape room uh with a
scary
song from the 90s uh the song should be
what they really want by dmx kind of a
deep cut
yeah but in the middle of the song it's
with cisco who was also the hottest
thing on the planet in 99 this one came
out nine years was that from
romeo must die soundtrack yes
it was with the movie with leah yeah so
uh in the middle of that song dmx just
goes on a tear and just lists all the
women in this neighborhood
in his gravely ass voice so he's like
there was brenda latisha
linda felicia yeah alicia
and he just goes on and on with all
these names so i feel like if this song
got the jordan peel treatment the way he
likes to like
remix tongues to make them scary oh yeah
yeah
that would be super scary to hear
echoing through an escape room
and every girl in there or every person
in there who could be named
teresa or brenda or lashawn which
actually could be a dude's name too
yeah i would be extra terrified in this
escape room so yeah what do you really
want by dmx
i love that um i'm going to give a two
shot so i'm just gonna fill up this
whole thing two shots one uh to angelico
one to
uh angelica just because they both sang
the song and i wanted to hear the song
um and uh they're actually scary sorry
tell me
gotta be scary uh so also boss your
hands are shaking
all right question number two disney
plus downloads reportedly surged 72
last weekend with the release of
hamilton on the service
what kind of intellectual property
crossover should disney do to take
advantage of their new streaming mega
hit
simple i got it it's a christmas
spectacular
burr a frozen story
aaron burr now disgraced after the
dueling death of alexander hamilton is
banished
to arendelle where he meets up with yolo
olaf zoloft kiki and the gang and they
go on
that's their names right i don't i don't
know frozen very well
they uh they get together
they they go on a frozen adventure of
both redemption
and friendship and at the end of the day
even in the coldest temperatures the
heart can grow warm
when we work together that's not the
theme of frozen
but i do it is the theme beautiful burr
a frozen christmas story
i love zoloft actually is olaf's
depressed cousin who always has
the uh snow cloud over his head you
can't get it up
because with them at all times so how
about
hercules mulligan teams up with hercules
okay
yeah there's hercules squared out here
and
they form this amazing just beautiful
bond because they're both such
passionate characters
i really think that this relationship
could go the distance
very nice and you know disney hercules
is up in it loving it making the ladies
say come again
absolutely with those biceps oh yes
please
uh all right what do you got all right
so i got the perfect disney hamilton
crossover right here
it's a movie or winter special whatever
have you
of the skylar sisters from hamilton
singing a duet or a bunch of duets with
the muses from hercules
so it's about these two groups of strong
boisterous women who have been relegated
to the sidelines or to backing you know
hercules
and hamilton so in this one they're
front and center it's their time to
shine
they're singing they're having
adventures they're talking trash
they're being silly they're being fully
fledged out
3d characters and since hercules is the
name of one of the titles
and hamilton's the name of one of their
titles their movie the skylar sisters
and the muses their movies called
oh i love that and i and i get this
picture of those muses going saying
ooh you think you got it skyler's
sisters are like yeah we think we got
it oh and uh i have to give you a point
there because
i know how much you actually dislike
hamilton or hate the craze of it
that was a real hurdle for you to jump
yeah no it's it's
it killed me three times it killed me
more than the bang is killing you but
it had to be done for this episode you
did it
uh for those of you watching this guy
wrote like one of the funniest sketches
that was like a parody of my shot where
it was like a guy refusing to go back to
the pantages
theater to uh where hamilton was showing
because he didn't want to give up his
parking spot and uh how did it go
i was uh i'm not giving up my spot yeah
you are [ __ ] out of luck and i don't
give a [ __ ] because i am not giving up
my spot
[Laughter]
it was so great all right moving on uh
thor actor chris hemsworth is going to
play professional wrestler
hulk hogan in a biopic for netflix
and your best wrestler voice can you cut
a promo as thor
let me tell you something brother i may
be the king of asgard
but next sunday you better guard your
ass
cause i'm coming for you i took down
thanos
i took down hella i took down loki
you want to talk about friends i'm
friends with the avengers
i'm friends with captain america i'm
friends with iron man rest in peace
i'm friends with scarlett johansson
i'm friends with spiderman i'm friends
with samuel l jackson
i'm friends with three larson i'm
friends with general thunderbolt frost
and i'm friends with these two iron
steel
pythons that'll come at you
ah it's a hard act to follow tommy gets
the shot
i i you know i defeated hello oh
i defeated him oh no loki can't even
fool me
i don't know she's still she's still
going you know what i'm gonna be doing
this
all night now i'm gonna be like this is
gonna keep me awake
the baby's gonna keep you awake eric
this is gonna keep me awake i'm just
gonna be like
and then eventually i'm gonna come up
with something really clever
and i'm gonna hop into the comments
section yeah
she's coming for you in the comments
brother that's the only
place that could ever truly hurt me all
right well i believe
erica wuzu is our winner of this episode
[Music]
do you have a wish that you'd like
bequeathed to you
uh i want to like mail this to you so
you can somehow
incorporate him in an episode of rogue
theory my plush pickle ring
oh apparently actually i can incorporate
them now
translate it through the power of the
internet as always
look at me oh existence is pain
in existence is pain for me
um i i immediately regret my decision
well that is it for this episode of
rogue theory thanks to our guests
uh tommy bottom line bec told bye
eric oh boy buddy i i just burped and i
tasted every meal that i ate for the
past week it was a reverse violet
beauregard from
uh angelica trey thank you for joining
us this week thank you for having me
uh joy i was a tune in to the next new
rock stars rogue
theory where eric actually injects bang
directly into his veins yes erica wusu
thanks for coming back and joining us
hey thanks for having me and thanks for
my w
my crown i don't know w sure it's uh
it's the king george crown
because we know how much you love
hamilton
so so much
well that is it for this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the rogue theory
podcast feed stay tuned for the
youtube channel for this and other shows
follow us on twitter at new rockstars
i've been eric boss you can find me on
instagram and other
places hopefully oh i i feel
powerful
[Music]
you